By now you may have gotten the big idea behind anti-lock braking systems.
Looking at this curve, it's obviously best to have a moderate amount of wheel slip, say, 0.2.
So the wheels must not be rolling perfectly. It's also not good if the wheels do not roll at all.
If they are locked, the wheel slip of about 0.2 would make more sense. This is the objective.
We have to have some type of technology that make sure the wheel slips stays around 0.2.
So that we apply the maximum amount of friction.
This ensures that the braking distance is as short as possible but it also ensures
the maximum amount of steerability.
The larger the friction is the better we can steer the car while it is braking.
You may ask yourself, okay, all of this is good and well but why don't we simply build a brake
that applies this amount of friction and then we're done with it.
No electronics, no sensors, no actuators whatsoever.
The problem is that this curve looks different under different circumstances.
With a higher speed, it may look like that.
When there's water on the road, it may look like that and so on.
So we do not know in advance which amount of friction would be best.
What we do know that the slippage of 0.2 almost always make sense.
Put note, a wheel slip of 0.2 actually does not make sense on snow and on sand.
If you're on snow and on sand, locking the wheels as quickly as possible is the best option.